Ladies and gentlemen, it is an historic day.
We now know that thanks to Democrats winning
both Senate runoffs in Georgia, Democrats
will have 50/50 in the Senate with Joe Biden
in the White House, meaning that in any cases
of a 50 50 tie in the Senate, the vice president,
Kamala Harris, will be allowed to cast the
deciding vote in practical terms, giving Democrats
control of the Senate.
What they will be able to get done, of course,
will depend on maintaining all 50 Democratic
senators united.
And it's almost cliche at this point to say,
but much of that will come down to does Joe
Manchin, the most conservative of the Democrats
in the Senate from West Virginia.
Does Joe Manchin want to do many of the things
that Joe Biden outlined in his presidential
platform?
Or will Joe Manchin be the thorn in the side
of the Democrats?
Now, of course, there are other Democrats
who in some cases may not want to go with
the Biden idea.
There are, at least theoretically, some Republicans
who might.
You know, the prototypical example is that
the constituents for Republican Maine Senator
Susan Collins may be more to the left of the
constituents for Democratic senator in West
Virginia, Joe Manchin.
And these are more detailed level discussions
that we will have in the future.
But what we do know is that in terms of the
Kelly Lefler incumbent versus challenger Raphael
Warnock race, that one was called relatively
early last night.
Official calls starting around.
And after midnight, David Wasserman unofficially
saying he had seen enough of the data to call
it right around.
I believe it was 930 p.m. Eastern, maybe 10
p.m. Eastern, something like that.
And indeed, that race has been now called
officially with Raphael Warnock ahead.
As of right now, with 98 percent reporting
by one point two percentage points.
The other race is incumbent Senator David
Perdue, a corrosive, vile, depraved influence
on the U.S. Senate who couldn't even be at
the last rally that Donald Trump held for
the Republicans because he was in isolation
due to covid exposure.
That one has has been called by some and not
others.
But it is it is over.
And officially as of right now, John USCIRF
with 98 percent reporting as of this moment,
leading by about half a point, roughly 16,
17000 votes.
And that one is also one that some have called
and some have not.
And by the time you listen to today's show,
you may see that it has also been called.
So consider that under Donald Trump, who won
in 2016, Donald Trump himself is ending up
as a one term president.
And we are just moments now.
And maybe by the time you listen to this,
it will already be underway.
We are moments now from the official counting
of the electoral votes, January 6th, the absolute
I think last date that Trump cultists were
saying this is the date where Mike Pence can
do something for us.
But Trump becoming a one term president, Democrats
taking the House of Representatives in twenty
eighteen and maintaining control in 2020,
although with a slightly smaller margin than
they than they achieved in twenty eighteen.
And Democrats also taking the Senate from
Republicans in 2020.
Back in 2017, the mathematical consensus was
pointing to unlikely that Democrats can take
the Senate in 2020.
But 2022 is certainly a possibility.
We now have a situation where Democrats thanks,
of course, to Kamala Harris in the White House,
Democrats now will have control 50 percent
plus that one tie breaking vote in the Senate
in 2020.
And the possibility, again, depends on what
you get done, but the possibility of expanding
the Senate majority in 2022, although we are
very much getting ahead of ourselves, let's
get this new president sworn in.
First and foremost.
I was thinking, by the way, back to remember
that debate between Kelly Leffler and challenger
Raphael Warnock, where she endlessly repetitively
smeared or attempted to smear him as radical
liberal.
Remember this radical liberal, Raphael Warnock,
radical liberal, Raphael Warnock, radical
liberal, Raphael Warnock, radical liberal
Raphael Warnock, radical liberal Raphael Warnock?
Well, as I tweeted last night, that's going
to have to be modified to be.
Radical liberal Senator Raphael Warnock to
you, Miss Leffler, and of course, he's not
really radical and that was just part of the
smear campaign.
So in the end, you know, we'll look at exit
polls and we already know that perspective
on Trump vs. Biden heavily influenced people's
votes in Georgia.
We know that there was some antipathy towards
Donald Trump's attempts to steal the election,
that Joe Biden legally won and legally won
quite easily, I might add.
That did not work in Donald Trump's favor.
And we'll have time to slice and dice the
results.
But in the immediate, the question for me
becomes, listen, politics is not sport.
For me, politics is how does this affect people's
lives?
And unfortunately, there are many for whom
it is merely sport.
And that's really a shame.
But we have a global year pandemic.
We have an eviction crisis.
We have high unemployment.
We've seen dramatic GDP reductions.
We have businesses that are closed for good
because of the virus.
We've seen growing inequality.
And there's this long and climate is is an
urgent crisis.
So there's this long list here of issues that
Joe Biden is going to have dropped on his
desk on day one.
What can he do via executive order?
What can he do legislatively in the first
100 days?
Joe Biden talking yesterday about if we get
these seats, then we're looking at two thousand
dollar checks.
Well, are you and how quickly can you get
that done?
Is that something we're going to do?
I joined up yesterday during our broadcast
of the Georgia results with Sam Ceder over
and over at the majority report.
And we talked about what is the what is the
trajectory here in terms of what's prioritized
with regard to the virus, Sam saying, well,
Biden should immediately invoke the Defense
Production Act and get businesses making millions
and millions of doses of the vaccine to accelerate
that process.
Because the sooner we reach herd immunity,
the sooner the economy is going to recover
and the sooner we can get back to dealing
with a whole bunch of other issues.
I think that that's something that's going
to have to be looked at.
But for those who my last thought on this,
I want to go to Republican reaction to this.
But my last thought and, you know, part of
the conversation here, we can't have until
we actually have that January six today, electoral
vote count in the rearview mirror.
I think a lot of us will just feel more ready
to talk about the first 100 days of this administration
and new Senate.
But I think the cautionary message is all
of these are moves in the right direction.
But there are small moves were just sort of
we've gotten the ball back.
We're starting to right the ship.
As I've said before, the anti intellectual,
anti science, delusional, extremist, authoritarian
when we want to be.
But otherwise we pretend to be constitutional
conservatives that this entire paradigm on
the right was built up, starting with Ronald
Reagan.
You could argue it goes back even further
to the civil rights movement and the sort
of reaction to the civil rights movement in
the late 50s and 60s.
But let's, for our purposes today, say that
the disinformation.
Right, that tries to win by lying to people
and disenfranchizing people.
It sort of goes back to the Reagan era with
the imaginary welfare queen who was sitting
around popping out kids and making money off
welfare to get a Cadillac.
That that was like the idea she never existed.
OK, this that Trump ism today and the Trump
cult really started with that.
And it took decades to build.
And so my only point here and then we'll move
on because there's so much to talk about.
My only point here is everything that's happened
in the last month, two months helps us to
start writing the ship.
But it would be unreasonable to imagine that
a problem that took 40 years to create is
going to be solved in two or in four.
And as I've said before, the only times that
you get radically fast cultural change, because
a lot of this comes down to culture, the antiscience
culture, the hypocrisy culture of this stuff
is all bad unless we want to do it, in which
case it's good that applies to debt, authoritarianism,
et cetera, from the right.
The only times we see radical changes to that
type of culture or when you have a dictatorship,
come in.
OK, so it's not realistic to think that a
Democratic Senate and Joe Biden is going to
dramatically change that in a two or four
year period.
So the focus has to be we get things done
that we can get done and we start to work
on that culture.
It's a big uphill battle.
But could there were two races and Democrats
won both of them.
You couldn't hope for a better result.